[Music]
you ever wonder what a pop star spends
her millions on well now we know I think
a good facial is amazing to feel
empowered
[Music]
my main thing is to enjoy life and the
numbers don't lie because at 35 years
old Brittany is living her best life
according to financial papers obtained
by ET Brittany spent more than ten point
nine million dollars in 2016 some of the
biggest expenses over one hundred and
twenty-two thousand dollars on massages
grooming and nails just under 70 grand
on wardrobe and around twenty five
thousand dollars on hair and makeup
while her little dog can be seen in the
background of her at home workouts when
she's away it costs roughly thirty
thousand dollars for their care that's
more than twice the average cost of
college tuition in California last
weekend Brittany spent the day at
Disneyland with her 23 year old
boyfriend Sam asghari and two sons Sean
and Jaden and last year she spent over
fifty nine thousand dollars on personal
travel
Britt can also be just like us shopping
at attainable stores like Target and
despite earning just under 16 million
dollars in 2016
she spent just five thousand seventy
dollars on gifts
[Music]